and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and I'm back baby together we
are the minimalist yes we are today
we're gonna talk about the pros and cons
of positive thinking with our returning
champion TK Coleman I love that you're
the first person to be on this podcast
four times
well besides me and Ryan right Ryan
you've been on here four times at least
yeah so I'm aiming to be the MJ Michael
Jordan for our listeners of this podcast
so I'm gonna make that insert so I'm
gonna appear six times and then I'm
gonna retire from all Pyke I think it's
a genius idea man I do you think you'll
push you off for that last nobody gets
that at all positive thinking with TK
Coleman you can check out his podcast
it's called office hours also TK Coleman
calm as his website discover practices
his business discover practice calm our
first question is from Shania and Bangor
Maine I'm 21 and I find it really hard
not to compare myself to people that are
27 much older and their successes and I
find it really hard to see in a constant
state of motivation that they feel like
everyone else's around me I feel like my
mental health effects are even though I
try not to let it so I guess my question
for you would be what are your guys's
biggest motivators and I'm when you're
struggling until you're just in your
everyday life how do you remind yourself
and so so that you can always be
nominated man I feel like comparisons
are like the biggest D motivators like
they can be right I think yeah maybe
both it depends what I try to compare
myself to it's like the most ideal
version of myself we actually did this
backwards we recorded the the maximal
episode before this and we were talking
about like if I'm just comparing myself
to Jason Momoa all the time it's a
problem that is gonna that's gonna be
very demotivating but if I compare
myself to the best version of myself
that that can be inspiring
what about motivation TK I don't know if
you need to feel motivated all the time
I don't even know if that's a healthy
thing to pursue so I I think I would I
would like to challenge you to release
yourself from whatever ideal you have
going on in your mind of what a
motivated person looks like and filling
the need to always strive towards that
you know when we talk about the pros and
cons of positive thinking I think one of
the cons is is it often leads to this
belief that feeling unhappy or
uninspired or unmotivated is a sin and
it's evidence that something is wrong
with me and and I think developing a
healthy relationship to the emotional
spectrum requires you to accept that
there is a broad range of feelings
required to be a complete human being
and you may have moments where you don't
feel motivated to pursue your goals well
guess what
some of the best dreams come from a
space other than filling motivated to
pursue your goals I mean as a
rudimentary example think about all the
great love songs all the great art that
has come from having your heart broken
and being in this space of like oh man I
can't believe she left me right or or
being in this space of like man I just
tried to achieve this thing and it
failed and I don't know if I have the
strenght to go on anymore and being in
that space for a few months there's so
much great art there are so many great
dreams there are so many great ideas
that come from a space that is different
from yeah I'm ready to go I'm ready to
be a part of the 1% and crush everything
like you don't always need to be in that
space it's okay to be a human being it's
okay to feel something other than the
inspiration necessary to do great those
are boring stories to men I just I woke
up and I started winning and then I won
the next day and I just kept winning
yeah now I'm just I'm just accepted that
I'm a winner I'm just always won we were
rooting against Golden State this year
is because like they had stacked the
deck for themselves so much right and
while you didn't want anyone to get hurt
is that one thing that you and TK do
agree on you both are rooting against
Golden State I don't know what his
thoughts were this
I was conflicted but I was rooting for
Kauai because he's this sort of
emotionless you know he's he's the new
John Stockton basically why is amazing.i
I called Toronto Raptors it's captured
on office hours I called it preseason
they're winning the finals called it
yeah well you told you guys next year I
saw that time yeah I'm gonna say that
repost it in the playoffs tell me how
well it but no yeah but to your point
though it's like it's the same reason
why like I rude against the Patriots in
football it's like okay great you guys
want some Super Bowls let someone else
win the Super Bowl six with Tom Brady
something like that even though yeah I
won't talk about it anymore but that's
the thing you look at that and unless
you're part of that tribe you identify
with the tribe you can act you can
recognize excellence and you can
appreciate that it's the reason I really
like someone like like a Tony Robbins
were you like that that guy seems
superhuman not in the sense that he's
not human but it's like human 2.0 almost
right like the next evolution and you
say you see that athletically with
someone like LeBron James he doesn't
just have the athleticism but he has the
athletic IQ we were talking about that
too how you can't really translate that
to to like sports biographies or
whatever but he he creates a game that
isn't just physical but its mental when
he's able to sort of bring the two
together you can appreciate that but
also at some point it may have been the
reason that I really liked you tall
growing up because I was like okay okay
the Bulls that this Michael Jordan guy
is like he he has the cheat code and I
tend to unless you're part of the tribe
lightly you know cuz TK is from Chicago
people up from the outside I recognize
his excellence but I'm tired of this I
want the humanity
I want John Stockton to win a title
because he's your every everyday guy
from the aspo Kane Washington and yeah
you know I the creative process has abs
and flows right has stages and a part of
being a part of what it means to become
a great creator is being available to
all the different dimension
of self that that is presented
throughout those different stages all of
life can't be spent at some peak state
where you're like let's go out and get
them let's go do something you know um
you need moments where you are very
sober and you're thinking to yourself
hmm why do I feel so upset about that
you need moments where you're filled
with passion because you observe
something in the world you don't like
and you say man that makes me mad
you need moments where you go watch a
basketball game or you go attend a
concert you need moments to be a great
human being um there's a theater
professor at Western Michigan University
Joan Herron Singh
she said the key to being a great artist
or a great creator is being a great
human being and that means you have to
have something else to think about
something else to devote yourself sooo
to something else to immerse yourself in
other than this thing you want to be
great at so I know you may have goals I
know you may have dreams and I know when
you look at the people around you you
want to feel really motivated all the
time but the key to having that motive
as motivation is investing in things
that will generate self-knowledge and
that means just be a human being release
yourself from that you don't have to be
motivated all the time but be curious
about wherever you are yeah and let it
teach you be present to what you're
feeling so they like to punctuate where
you're saying to UK like I totally need
to be punctuated yeah you uh you you you
you cannot be motivated hundred percent
of time but that's good news because
like you said you can give yourself
permission to like be okay with not
being motivated instead of feeling like
it's a sin to not be motivated yeah
however I do think there are ways we can
kind of get this motivation going and I
think maybe like for me there's I wrote
down a few ways of what I do when I when
I'm feeling like I'm let just have no
motivation all really what I kind of
look for is inspiration somehow so I can
do that through a book I can do that
through a blog post I can go through a
podcast episode I can do that through
having you know meaningful conversation
with you guys yeah we can talk about
that go for it well just to me real
quick like inspiration comes from the
outside motivation is internal right and
so if you're having trouble with the
internal side of things quite often it's
where am I going to find the best
inspiration because you can also get
negatively inspired if you what's the
saying you are the some of the five
people you surround yourself with
and if the five people you surround
yourself with are demotivating they're
negative they're gonna inspire you to
feel like crap right I would what
motivation is the internal one yeah an
inspiration is external and I would I
would say that like motivation I think
huh it has to start with inspiration
doesn't it no no Sara Lee I mean I think
you can you can have someone who's close
to an enlightened state where they don't
require the the inspiration outside in
fact III think there there are certain
people who are more self motivated than
than other people and more some people
require more inspiration there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing yeah
inherently good about that either so
maybe uh maybe a way it may be a
different way to phrase it is maybe
inspiration is like a not a cheat code
but it is what it is one possible way to
get you to be internally motivated but I
you're right like motivation doesn't
have to come from inspiration meaning if
I got a problem I'm gonna be motivated
to solve it I don't need to hear TK's
take on it to solve this problem that I
have in front of me but you might get
motivated by TK if so if your problem is
I have a flat tire and you go to TK and
you because you're like I've never
changed a flat tire I know what to do
and he's like oh yeah I just had a flat
tire last week and here are the three
C's I did to solve that problem you like
okay now I realize there's hope on the
horizon I realized there is a recipe and
so that has now inspired me I feel more
motivated because I don't feel the
despair of oh my god I'm never gonna be
able to change his tire I don't even
know what to do what is a tire yeah yeah
I think when I was thinking about this
question the William Faulkner saying
where he said you know only right when
inspiration strikes fortunately it
strikes at 9:00 a.m. every morning and
like to me like that's that's putting in
the work yeah like that it like when I
think about you when I think about Colin
right when I think my podcast Sean like
you guys are I look at you guys like god
I wish I was that motivated because you
guys are always I feel like you put in
like way more work than what than when I
put into when it comes to reading when
it comes to writing I mean I still put
the work in but not as much and I so I
kind of get caught in thinking like oh
that's because I lacked the motivation
but when I really look at it it's like
Colin right he's right like on tour he's
writing in the backseat discipline it's
not motivation
exactly exactly bub delineate the to Tk
discipline
motivation yeah I mean I think it's an
ingredient to motivation to a certain
extent right because that that quote
that Ryan just quoted there was I think
it's spot-on what he's really saying is
I have the discipline to write every
morning even when I'm not motive and
when you become disciplined I think like
the motivation actually will start to
come now it doesn't it doesn't mean that
like every single morning at 9:00 a.m.
he's inspired like he might put in an
hour worth of writing and like throw his
hands in the air after and be like that
was worthless and delete you know the
2,000 words that he wrote that day talk
about that on patreon like writing is
noticing ultimately that that is and so
he has to show up and notice every
morning at 9:00 a.m. and if you're
noticing that will start to motivate yes
yeah really like that all right there
one more thing in so motivation is also
contextual sometimes when we say I'm
having a hard time motivating myself
what that really means is there's this
thing I think I should be doing and when
I try to force myself to do it
I feel really unmotivated how can I
trick myself into wanting to do this
thing that I don't want to do and I
think sometimes a good question to ask
yourself in those moments is not how can
I motivate myself to do XYZ but rather
what am I already motivated to do in
this moment even if it's something other
than what I think I ought to be doing so
you see this for instance in study it's
it's a fact that we can only pay
attention to something for so long
before we need a break right so maybe
you're you're listening to a lecture or
you're reading a book and there comes a
point where you stop feeling motivated
but you've made the mental judgment that
a good thing for me to do right now was
to read this entire book or read this
entire chapter but your motivations gone
well you can force yourself to finish
but you can also say well what am i
motivated to do because what I don't
like or what I don't feel inspired by is
as instructional as what I do like and
what I do feel inspired by and you might
find in that moment that you do feel
motivated to take a walk and think about
what you just read you you do feel
motivated to watch a movie you do feel
motivated to call up a friend and
discuss the ideas
it becomes a problem when when I am
motivated to just do things that pacify
me so writing is an example that Ryan
brought up but let's say like I'm really
feeling motivated to watch youtube
videos right now the watching YouTube
video is not inherently good or bad but
following down that right I tend to be
more motivated by unmotivated to eat a
piece of chocolate cake as opposed to
I'm motivated to do something that's
healthy yeah so so one is the path of
least resistance one is the path of
pleasure and I think we mistake pleasure
with payoff and the real payoff doesn't
have a lot of pleasure always in the
middle there's drudgery there is
difficulty there is discipline there is
habit forming and and the real payoff
those on the other side of the real
payoff isn't on the other side of the
chocolate cake once you've eaten it I
don't know anyone who says I'm really
happy I ate a piece of chocolate cake
last month right I'm really happy I'm
eating it right now maybe right but that
pleasure is so fleeting and I think the
same is true with well if I'm just
skipping around from what motivates me
to what motivates me then I'm not
actually putting in the work so let me
touch on that because I think I think
you're right and it's important we make
a distinction here so let's say health
like eating healthy is the thing I'm not
motivated to do okay one alternative to
that would be to say well what do I feel
motivated to do I feel motivated to eat
chocolate cake okay let's do that all
right we can agree that that's probably
not a good idea that that there are some
alternatives that are bad but even then
there are a lot of people that would say
well you might want to build in a cheat
day because that can help but let's not
get into that but what we could say is
your your lack of motivation is still
very instructional and it might not be
the healthiest thing for you to just try
to override it with a let me trick my
brain technique because eating healthy
is it is a thing that has a diverse
range of possibilities there's no one
way to eat healthy and if you're not
motivated to eat healthy that could be
an indicator that there's some
particular approach to eating healthy
that you should be unmotivated by and if
you just try to force yourself to
surpass that then you're going to miss
out on the opportunity to learn an
approach to eating healthy
works for you so I think whenever you
feel unmotivated you don't just override
it and you don't just choose the easiest
thing to do and that's what you touched
on don't choose the easiest thing to do
what you touched on is don't just
override it but there's also this middle
ground of saying hey maybe there is a
way of eating healthy that my buddies
aren't in doing but that works for me I
experienced this with working out most
of my friends their approach to working
out it revolves around this I want to be
the next Dwayne rock Johnson methodology
that I just never have connected with
I'm not trying to be an action star in
the movies I'm not trying to go to the
gym and impress people like I need a way
of doing it that works for me right and
when I - so for you the measurement
isn't vanity muscles it is health right
and so even that is nebulous right as i
how do i define how it might be feeling
good well what does that even mean right
and so getting clear on what it means
for some people their idea of health
might be well I need to have I can't
have a six-pack I need to have an eight
pack of ABS right and and and so they're
defining it that way and they're really
awkward it was an indicator there
because she did say she's looking at all
the other people around her so it is
very likely that her lack of motivation
is stemming from this comparison based
ideal of what she ought to feel
motivated to do so I think for her it
might be useful to say well what do you
feel motivated to do and let's look at
the range of those options because I'm
sure it includes more than just eating
chocolate cake and let's see what
opportunities for for for customization
can be found there yeah sure I want to
give you a copy of our book everything
that remains it's it's a memoir and
we're actually talking about this on the
patriotic it's a self-help memoir in a
way though right yeah and so it is sort
of a story of positive thinking but not
just positive thinking also the actions
that Ryan and I took while thinking
positively because sometimes positive
thinking can get in the way but bakashot
if you could reach out to - should I
give her a copy of the book either the
audiobook if you like our podcast show
like the audiobook or if you want the
book book or the e-book we'll be happy
to send those to you as well everything
that remains it's my favorite thing that
we've ever written Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media
indeed we
view we are at the minimalists on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram TK
Coleman is TK underscore Coleman on
Twitter you can tweet him there follow
him there check out all of his pithy
answers and and correspond with him
let's see uh Nancy what is she saying
Ryan Nancy wants to know practicing
positive thinking can make it easier to
feel uplifted but negative thinking
helps identify potential issues to
prepare for how can i balance the
benefits of both good question I seem to
have to tread lightly with my veganism
as much as anyone's political or
religious views I thought it was nice
she added that last sentence there Ryan
Lightman it was a broad question until
she got into the veganism thing so my
pet the answer is and by the way we do
these tweetable answers but you as you
know you've been on here a bunch of
times we can just ramble on a little bit
and then Sean will tweeze out something
pithy but my pity answer is Dogma is the
enemy of understanding and and and
really what I mean by that is when we
pick an ideology and stop questioning it
that's what I mean by Dogma and whether
that is a political viewpoint I will
always vote for this the person with the
red tie or the blue tie or I will always
vote for veganism is it can be the same
thing we that's why we did the podcast
we had Rich roll and Paul Saladino on
here a carnivore and a vegan together
but I don't see either one of them as
have a particular Dogma they have a
philosophy but they're also open and by
the way they both have the heart of a
servant and that was what was important
they just get there via two different
paths I don't see a dogma
and so yeah I think we do have what does
she say my practice and positive thing
can make it easy to feel uplifted but
negative thinking helps identify
potential issues to prepare for yeah I
don't think that's negative thinking I
think that's maybe being realistic
yeah in a way that's actually what I was
thinking about when I first read this
question my pity answer is it's possible
to prepare for the worst while having a
half-full glass so it's like yeah you
can totally have a positive attitude of
a positive mental
- shout-out to Stan Dukes PMA that was
this thing but but yeah it's like the
the the preparation for the backlash
someone's gonna mean in her case I mean
she brings up veganism if she's just
like going on Twitter and yelling out
Meat Is Murder
like she's creating division and she's
got to be aware though like yeah when I
do this I am gonna create division I am
you know there's an exclusiveness that's
coming along with this it's it's very
it's very important to consider like how
your message is going to be received but
you can do that and still have a
positive attitude at the same time maybe
if I were to sum that up in a tweet the
best way to proselytize is not to
proselytize yeah yeah I like that I like
that yeah yeah you know i-i've said
before that I think the best way to
approach positive and negative thinking
is just by transcending that false
dichotomy I mean you don't need to slap
a label on the kind of thinking that you
have what really matters is is it
building you up or is it tearing you
down is it making you healthier or
making you less healthy is it moving you
in the direction that you want to go in
or is it moving you in the opposite
direction is it self nourishing and self
edifying or is it self defeating and
those are the aunt those are the only
questions that matter if a thought is
self-defeating it doesn't matter if you
can slap a positive label on it because
you're negating who you are if the
thought is building you up doesn't
matter if people slap a negative label
on it it's helping you go where you want
to go so think mostly about the results
that matter most to you what kind of
lifestyle you want to create inwardly
and outwardly and adopt the kind of
thoughts that move you in that direction
and who cares if people say oh you're a
negative person or you're a positive
person are you living in alignment with
your ideals yeah that's what matters
most because it's like I mean I think
about like when you say that I think
about like a video game streamer okay I
don't watch them but I know that they
exist and let's say someone who like
they watch the streams more than they'll
actually play the games now they like
just it's crazy it's like yeah kids
these days but not like it's like you
know minecraft I know I know of the game
minecraft I kind of know what it kind of
involves but like people hate that
what they do for a living they sit there
and they play Minecraft I look at that
person I'm like you're wasting your time
why aren't you putting your energy into
something more you know beneficial for
society and like there's all these
judgements that I have like these these
you know ostensible judgments that I
have however like in their world like
all they have to be worried about is are
they living up to their own expectation
doesn't matter what I think about them
like if they really enjoy the game
minecraft and like other people are
getting value from watching them play
minecraft then like more power to them
but I mean I think that's what you're
trying to say is like it doesn't matter
what other people think about you really
matters is what what you think about you
I'm gonna give you guys a math problem I
could be getting myself in trouble this
is a maths podcast I'm gonna be a bad
problem I'm way to solve this form area
five plus x equals zero I want you to
solve for X 5 plus negative 5 equals 0
negative 5 but that's a negative number
oh oh no he used a negative number did
you hear him
it solved the equation right yeah this
doesn't matter does it really matter he
solved the equation mmm that's all that
matters he got the answer that he needed
it doesn't matter if it's negative or if
it's positive like don't get caught up
with those labels solve the equations
that matter to you in your that's that's
that's that's tweetable that's good man
all right Krissi as someone who was
raised in the JW cult I know you put
this in here for me milli
JW coach job is witness call okay so as
someone who was raised in the job as
Witness cult was physically mentally and
sexually abused how can I stay positive
despite PTSD triggers it's funny when I
read this question I looked up the
difference between a cult and a religion
and it's funny cuz like even like the
definitions that I found like you could
look at Jehovah's Witnesses or a lot of
other Scientology a lot of other
religions as cults because there are
identifiying but you can also look at it
as religions so that's really my my
polite way of saying like I'm not
backing her statement of that J dubs or
a cult right this is her question yeah
this is her question ok understand why
her question if she was mentally sexual
yeah physic
well in fact that and that is why it
would be a Coulter because that is a
cultish that's a problem with one of the
cults like basically illegal things
happening that are being brushed under
the rug you know people I grew up
Catholic and you grab jobs with us we
both know people close to us who were
molested by the church oh yeah it's
crazy like why not because as a
Jehovah's Witness you're not supposed to
like read outside of their material like
they have an organization embody of
there's not like a specific number but
there's these gentlemen in place who put
out all this information and that's the
only information you're supposed to read
and when I started reading facts it is
mind-blowing
like how much stuff that like actually
does get covered up it's crazy anyway
you want to go first you want to go
first
well my pithy answer is the exact same
as it was for the previous one and this
I think ultimately leads to
understanding is Dogma is the enemy of
understanding right and so so one thing
that she has to do is she now has a very
narrow worldview and understandably of
like well all Jehovah's Witnesses are
bad that's creating your own dogma
because you're going against another dog
right there are some very austere saying
like there are some very awesome
Jehovah's Witnesses out there but in her
experience there aren't right because
what you're doing is you're creating a
label that says other right yeah and and
maybe we were having a really great race
conversation a moment ago and it was
like it was sort of about like people
identifying these these this other group
and saying well your other and then I'm
different from that and I think that I
think that you're creating out of one
dogma often stems a separate dogma and
we have to be really careful about that
but also we have to understand like
where how did you get to where you are
right and an understanding of how you
got where you are does help you let go
it helps you forgive and if I were to
give you another pithy answer I would
say letting go is the ultimate
superpower because in order to but in
order to let go you you also
they have to you have to understand how
you got here yeah yeah my pet the answer
is this PTSD can be like a bad car
accident you might need to seek
professional help to mend the wounds so
Chrissy yeah you know posit having a
positive attitude isn't going to undo
all the the terrible harm that has
happened to you and especially if your
experience on a PTSD like there are
professionals out there who help deal
with this trauma and to work through
that trauma that you have yeah I think
and we talked about that in the maximal
episode how I just have a positive
attitude it'll fix you like no like a
positive attitude is not all you need
right now Chrissy like you might need to
really like talk to someone
professionally to help mend these wounds
I mean it's and the reason why I liken
it to a bad car accident is because you
know if I was in a car accident broke my
leg I'm not gonna try and set my leg by
myself like I'm gonna go to the hospital
and like have my leg fix I'm gonna have
it mended by someone who knows how to do
that and PTSD is I mean it's just you
know instead of a physical trauma it's
mental drama but it's still trauma yeah
and you'll do you'll do what you can for
the time being but then ultimately
you're going to go to the professional
to help you out right yeah yeah you know
that's a real good example too because
sometimes when people ask how can I stay
positive in spite of this thing that
happened to me it means like hey how
what are some tips for how I can can
tough it out and not let this affect me
and then that that that easily slides
into a sense of if I allow myself to be
affected by it
that means I'm weak that means I'm a bad
person that means I'm not fulfilling my
moral responsibility and and I just want
to say you have the right to be affected
by whatever affects you if somebody hurt
you you have the right to be honest and
say this hurts if it happened a long
time ago you have the right to say and
it still hurts if you know somebody who
got over their hurt faster than you you
have the right to hurt as long as their
hurts for you and I would change the
frame from how can I stay positive in
spite of what happened to me to how can
i optimize for the healthiest kind of
life that I can live given what I have
been through I'm sorry that that
happened to you
you're a situation
is is unique to you and what you have to
do is optimize for health and that means
you've got to seek out the relationships
the alliances and the conversations that
are gonna help you get what you need and
to follow up on on Ryan's suggestion I
would I would strongly encourage you to
find someone that you trust
who's got the professional skill because
coming out of coats and dealing with
mental and physical abuse is an area
where there are professionals who are
trained and equipped with a lot of tools
to help people process those experiences
and as a non professional in that area I
would highly encourage you to at least
have an initial conversation with
someone who is experienced with helping
others who have gone through similar
things so that you can get what you need
to be healthy in life yeah absolutely
the one thing I will say about having a
positive attitude in this situation for
Christine I guess I did think of one way
that it could help her is like the hope
that we were talking about in the
maximal episode I mean there it's okay
for Chrissie to hang on to some system
hope that things can get better if she
uses you know the tools available to to
get through this trauma that she's been
through so there is hope Chrissie and
that's that's maybe the the takeaway
here with when it comes to positive
thinking is don't lose hope or even even
better find the hope yeah where is your
hope because hope says something about
your future and when you have hope then
I feel like you can move forward
accordingly we've got a bunch more
surprise questions this week what's the
best way to seek critical feedback
without sacrificing positive thoughts
what about people who have a hard time
being positive isn't being positive the
same thing as being delusional is the
self-help industry just a bunch of fluff
when is it okay to wallow and sadness or
anger what's the best solution to racism
what a what a strange conversation that
turned into and also I'm gonna read a
email argument with with my doctor the
first line of the his email was positive
thinking doesn't work and then we'll go
back and forth on that argument there
and if you want to hear all of that you
can listen to this week's maximal
episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right your
current listen to our weekly minimal
episode but each week Ryan and I and
this week TK and I and Ryan and I we
recorded a entirely different much
longer long-form maximal episode on the
minimalists private podcast it's a place
that gives us a space to talk about a
lot of things we don't typically talk
about in public
Plus patreon is the best way for us to
fund this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
and your favorite podcast app you also
get access to our entire back catalogue
of more than 100 private podcast
episodes find all the details and all
the good stuff including an additional
private podcast episode every week over
at the minimalists com
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us this week being informed is more
important than ever these days so I just
want to encourage people like I usually
do to read more and get informed and now
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners my favorite part
hi my name is Katherine I currently live
in the Bay Area and I was calling to
comment on your episode 3 which talks
about children and what I do with my
children that helps every first week of
December with clutter my children go
through all of their toys and we wash
them we clean them we put them in cute
little bags and then we donate them to
centers around our community and they
love acting like Santa and sharing their
toys or something
it gives us kind of that pre Christmas
purge period also we have we live in an
RV full time and so having that limited
of space has definitely helped us with
the grandparents and that kind of stuff
with they give us more experiences then
stuff since they know we just physically
don't have room
hello Josh hello Ryan my name is Sandra
and I currently live in Zurich
Switzerland I want to recommend the
books that might hopefully bring a lot
of inspiration to you and your listeners
in my profession as a designer I have
found myself often challenged with the
consumption oriented mindset of the
industry and although I work in
publishing mostly designing books I
would still find myself often wishing
that I could bring more of a positive
change into this work with my work but I
never really knew how then I found a
book called the little red book about
how to make design matter by David
Carlton and it inspired me so much that
I decided to share it with you in my
opinion any person designer or not can
find value in it because it encourages
the reader to make their work more
meaningful and then guides you with
simple inspiring examples I really can't
express enough how much this book has
changed for me that has made a change
for me and how I find it I now feel to
make all the ideas happen alright y'all
thanks again today to TK : TK if people
want to check out more of you office
hours podcast I think it's a great place
to go where else should they go yeah go
to the office hours podcast write a lot
of blogs and put a lot of material out
there on discover practices calm and
also my personal blog TK Coleman calm I
don't blog every day but you know it's
like I'm intimidated by and I'm like I
write every day usually but I don't
publish something every day now so I'm
getting stuff in my inbox from but I
will say this to you TK you are one of
my favorite public think thinkers public
intellectuals what are you gonna call it
but I really appreciate your public
ruminations and I'm really grateful that
Eamonn world has you man you're a good
friend you're a good person and I'm
really grateful thanks for being here
man I love you guys I appreciate that
can I get one more plug I want to plug
an idea and a resource I wrote a book
alongside Isaac Morehouse called freedom
without permission and there's an entire
chapter that's gonna take you a lot
deeper than what I can cover here that I
think is very apropos to our discussion
on the pros and cons of positive
thinking but I talk about two important
concepts that I think are necessary to
have a good
discussion on this topic one is
emotional versatility and I talk about
that as a viable alternative to
happiness that the goal of life is not
to be happy but it's to be emotionally
versatile and I talked about the concept
that I call psychological choreography
which is the ability to find your rhythm
in any emotional state where I compare
moods to genres of music and I and I
liken happiness to those kinds of to
those forms of music that we have an
easy time dancing to so as an example if
you've ever gone to a wedding there's
always a song like YMCA or a happy by
Pharrell that everybody including your
uncle who can't dance can have a good
time too because out person yeah yeah
because there are certain songs that
don't punish you for not having a good
rhythm you can jump up and down you can
just move your body any kind of way and
you'll look totally fine
happiness is like that song when you're
happy you never pick up the phone and
call up a buddy and go hey man I'm just
feeling so good today what do I do with
these emotions like you know that
there's no there's no sense of confusion
that comes with happiness because it's
like a song or a genre of music that's
really easy to dance to but let's go
back to the wedding and let's say you're
on the dance floor and happy' by
pharrell is playing and we're all having
a good time but then the music stops and
now polka comes on now jazz comes on
this is a genre of music that's a little
bit more complex it's harder to dance to
and so what does everybody do everyone
kind of removes themselves from the
floor because we don't know what to do
when that kind of music is on because it
will punish you for making the wrong
move and these are the forms of music
that require a deeper understanding to
know what to do because you can't just
go on the dance floor and do anything to
polka music there's a certain way you
have to find your rhythm in order to be
able to make it work and those are what
like our non happy emotions are like
that's what jealousy is like that's what
sadness is like and that's why we pick
up the phone and call a buddy when we
feel those emotions and we respond
differently than when we have happiness
because we don't know how to find our
rhythm in those states and but just like
any form of music you can learn how to
dance to it you know and it requires a
different way of moving
body a different way of adapting to it
but you can learn and I talked a little
bit about that in that book but I just
want to say to anyone who's listening I
don't think the goal of life is to force
yourself to be positive all the time or
to force yourself to feel good all the
time the goal of life is to be fully
human it's to be fully alive and
sometimes that involves recognizing that
there's a wide gamut of feelings and
it's about learning how to relate
harmoniously to the whole emotional
spectrum and learning how to incorporate
that into the creative process that is
life itself freedom without permission
all right let's put a link to that in
the show notes podcast Sean and if you
send us some copies we'll give us some
out on air as well again Oh real quick
four right here right now this is where
we talk about one thing that's going on
in the life of the minimalists so we we
made a decision recently that was not an
easy decision to make but sometimes we
we have to identify what enough is right
we're always as human beings it feels
like the human condition is about more
more and more at least if it's not the
human condition it's the consumeristic
condition and I need to get more we
don't even know why we're pursuing more
sometimes and so we just think the more
is the goal of the thing right Ryan and
I made a difficult decision we're
capping our patreon audience at 6,000
people and so you're roughly 2% of our
overall listening audience and the
reason we're doing that is because it's
well it's a place where we have these
sort of private discussions like we just
had right and we feel unencumbered and
it's a place that we can we can have
difficult discussions we can have first
drafts of discussions in a way we can
let our hair down a bit without fear of
judgement or ridicule or these other
things because it's a group of people
who who understand us to a certain
extent now we might not always agree
they might not agree with us and we
accept that right but it's a smaller
group of people and what we've realized
is this thing has grown significantly in
the last four months our patreon has
doubled in size and I'm assuming with
that trajectory we're gonna get to that
cap relatively soon when I don't know
but I want to curate an audience and we
we figure
a number that was our minimum viable
audience as Seth Godin might call it
right and say hey that's enough for us
and it makes sense because growing for
the sake of growth is that's cancer
right if he was growing to grow to grow
why are you growing for us this is a
place that allows us to pay podcast
Shawn and Jordan and Jess in the studio
space and also ourselves and have this
podcast 100% advertisement free but we
don't need to grow in perpetuity and I
like having this small space where we
can test out new ideas without having to
worry about well can't believe I just
said that I thought it was because we
came up with an algorithm and figured
out that happiness
[Laughter]
so we figured out what enough was for us
and so you're welcome to join us there
patreon.com slash the minimalist if you
want otherwise you can keep listen to
the minimal episodes as well if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or send a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you want our show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm and you'll
also receive our simple Sunday emails
each week and for our added value this
week let's listen to a song from the
king of positive music happy music this
is like dance Florida wedding music for
sure like wait I have an album Jason
Mraz he every time he's one of these
guys that is sort of like relatively
one-track music but does happy music
really really well and I didn't know he
came out with a new album last year it's
called no is the name of the album cool
yeah I turned it on
when I was picking back Sandell up from
the airport a couple weeks ago and like
I was just in the backseat dancing she's
singing the words doesn't even know the
words she's like singing along with it
and it's like that's great it does
change the way that you feel all of a
sudden like you can be in this negative
sort of mood you turn on Jason Mraz song
and all of a sudden you're feeling you
feel a bit more positive so Christmas
does that to Christmas music yeah yes
indeed here is have it all from Jason
Mraz's latest album no and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening
we'll see you next time bye and minimus